ah yes the magical mystical st.
Patrick's Day has its own town almost
that be like nothing but drunk people
and overcrowded bars and a never-ending
walk of shame it was a long time ago
also narration now you probably wondered
where holidays come from not really but
I've always assumed that they came from
corporations looking to make extra bucks
but something tells me this movie isn't
nearly that cynical one minute and 30
seconds in and stop-motion puppet movie
gives up and just animates ghosts
singers the traditional cartoon way
change character who gets slipped deadly
nightshade later only has himself to
blame since it just happened recently
before this movie's plot began fool me
twice
yeah but didn't that song you were
singing say you scare people but not
actually drain their blood right street
musicians the dog goes character though
that character is important enough to do
in stop-motion and add a glow to as
opposed to simply drawing him like the
other ghosts I had to write because she
definitely couldn't just stuff some
leather with leaves on her own that's
twice this month use the deadly
nightshade into my tea and run off damn
she's already fooled dude twice shame on
you for sure motherfucker you're mine
you know I made yo with my own Creator
chastise his creation for being itself
huh it's like this dog ghost isn't even
dead at all so let me ask this Jack
Skellington is dead but he's not a ghost
but his dog is a ghost so how does one
thing turn into a ghost and another
stays an animated corpse
why does Halloween town need both a king
and a mayor he's not home he hasn't been
home all night
thank goodness these three dudes have no
essential town function other than to
keep tabs on the comings and goings at
the Skellington home Jack finds the
mystical doorway to the other holiday
lands just by walking for a long time
something he and none of the other
inhabitants of Halloweentown have ever
done apparently I really want to see
this movie in an alternate dimension
where Jack chooses the
amrok door instead of Christmas town
well let's see that so hard oh yeah
let's not forget Thanksgiving town where
everyone wishes it was Christmas already
this magical portal for all the holidays
did not include Hanukkah because the
magical portal is racist and Jack goes
to Christmas town he falls through a
weird time space warp abyss thing but
then the movie never explains how he
gets back it's not like there's a ladder
he could climb up discount who bill his
children throwing snowballs instead of
throwing heads haha but how do you know
the word snow and what it means
considering 40 seconds ago you saying
what's this there's white things in the
fire hazard oh the children are asleep
but look there's nothing underneath
no ghouls I would there be even in
Halloweentown don't you wait until
Halloween to do all that scary stuff I
don't you do it all in England France
and Kentucky and not in Halloweentown
what's Jack is a dick - sleeping kids I
vampires are dumb and are dicks -
Cyclops why do you continue to let her
cook for you impossible spoon storage
also Sally uses a strainer spoon that
somehow does not give away that it's a
strainer spoon when you look at it on
the backside also thank God in heaven he
decides to drink it all in one slurp
straight from the bowl because otherwise
he'd have needed a spoon and with his
under the table he'd have asked for
yours which is fake and has holes and
you'd be caught again how did Jack get
back either he walked out of Christmas
town and found the three portals
immediately which is something it took
his whole life to do in Halloweentown or
he found a way to portal himself out of
Christmas town without any help
Hey look I'm all for trees that could
walk and have facial expressions but how
the hell did it get inside the Town Hall
through this opening feast
but they don't understand wait not this
was a town meeting so why are the
curtains closing like this was a
performance and he's not even allowing
the demons to ask any more questions
Jack Skellington expects the whole town
to understand Christmas after a song all
of these books are way too big for the
subjects promised by their titles why
does this ghost dog even bother to sleep
in his grave when he has his whole house
he can stay in cute but this is
mathematically impossible Chris Matt
phone cock haha because he's already
dead right I don't really know but it
brings up the question can you really
die like go away forever in this world
also these people are not only worried
about Jack after less than 24 hours but
also think he might have died just
because he hasn't come out of his house
to say something let these Christmas
book so many times I know the stories
and they know the rhymes in 24 hours
this book is written backwards and it's
about clans what kind of clan Jack
Skellington Jack trust these assholes
nothing about the mister oogie-boogie
that we meet later suggests he's the
type of monster who throws the cages of
his meals back up the meal pipe tub
travel it's going to be a disaster how
could it be just follow the pattern
comic misunderstanding for plot purposes
how did these dumb assholes catch the
Easter Bunny I'm assuming the Easter
Bunny like most bunnies is fast I don't
think even know where to look and how
they stealin without anyone stopping
them they travel by table I'm not buying
this hilarious scenario even after the
three idiot miscreants bring back the
Easter Bunny Jack still trust the big
Santa Claus kidnapping to them what
after no sign of this guy allmovie
suddenly there's an Igor assistant
asshole why the hell didn't you ask this
prick to make your soup instead of
trusting that task to the girl who was
poison you multiple times already
without ever having given us an on
Halloween town perspective movie
suddenly starts showing us Christmas
town in conjunction with Halloween Town
because parallels
now who could that be it took these
assholes more than a month to go back
and try and kidnap Santa did Jack just
forget about Santa after they stole the
Easter Bunny over 30 freakin days ago it
only took us 32 days but finding him
sooner would have interrupted our
jacking off schedule thankfully for
Santa boogie prefers musical numbers and
chants to any kind of common sense or
efficiency consequences Santa decides to
object to his torture in rhyme and meter
of the spontaneous song the villain is
singing the reindeer can't see an inch
in front of their noses
what a brilliant nose you have the
better to light my way she warned reason
for Rudolph Ghost Dog is shoehorn that
kind of favoritism these others skeleton
zombie reindeer are ever gonna let poor
Xero play any skeleton zombie reindeer
games just a few minutes into Christmas
and Jack is already half-assing it which
is probably why Halloween is usually
such a lame holiday also all these
people are so anxious for Christmas that
they're literally standing by the
fireplace waiting for gifts with one
hand on the light switch at these Asian
puppets racist I don't know maybe they
aren't but I swear I'm watching some
propaganda film from the 1940s when I
see them we're just bonding them hey
wait a minute
when did the police station get all
these extra phones just a second ago
they only had one that's cheating
reports are pouring in from all over the
globe why is the radio news person on
duty in the middle of the night a kindly
old grandmother should be a middle-aged
smoking white dude in a Slayer t-shirt
Jack just happens to be flying over the
very area where anti-aircraft weapons
are installed also it's amazing how
easily this town decided that murdering
the Santa imposter was the best thing to
do especially since his biggest crime is
delivering scary toys also cops get some
calls about a fake Santa immediately
opened fire on things in the sky
okay boogie he was attracted to human
female legs do-do-do-do-do oh man did
oogie-boogie ever slay women back in the
day with his foot tickling technique
who's next on my list his list is first
names only and contains no addresses or
scheduled gifts but Jack apparently has
all the information he needs and if you
hadn't already shown us that he could
pull his head off without dying and is
already dead that might mean something
nobody in law enforcement or the
military or even as much as the fire
department bothered to come check out
the burning sleigh how come the
Halloweentown people were able to watch
Jack's actions in the TV bowl thing all
the way up to the sleigh explosion but
nothing afterwards went the part where
he survived huh also now that I bring it
up how the fuck did they have the same
POV of Jack's events as we did that's
amazing if they have this kind of view
of Earth's but how the fuck have they
never heard of Christmas before now why
does nothing when I could NAB someone
and steal a holiday ruination of entire
Christmas boils down to identity crisis
Sandy Claws any gram on earth is
apparently a direct pathway to
Halloweentown Oogie takes time to mana
long for no reason giving Jack more time
to sneak in and stop his murder attempt
I'd like to see this guy and two-face
get into a battle with each other one
rolls dice the other flips coins they
leave everything to chance like it's
Dungeons and Dragons or some cheating
I'm Santa Claus when you were tied up a
few seconds ago Santa you could pretty
easily have touched your nose if that's
all it takes to get the fuck out of
Dodge
I'm just saying have I mentioned this
town's extremely liberal attitude
towards kids being up at this hour this
kid is still holding that hand from like
God it's been hours right don't forget
it at the heart of this weird-ass
holiday mashup was a love story all
along for some reason
[Music]
also okay so how old Jack and Sally have
sex he has no penis probably and she has
a Frank in China so it would be tough to
do anything other than hug Tim Burton
said okay Henry you will get the
directors credit on this movie but it
will come at the end and my name will be
above the title
and people will forever think of this as
my movie and my movie alone you cool
with that ever since cinemasins began
the most requested thing has been TV
since and now it's a reality click the
link in the description below to check
it out and now the audio outtakes
sobbing beeping do you know how easy
this is for me do you have any idea how
easy this is a fucking joke tearing me
apart
you got a me partly job
[Music]
what is that yellow you'll have to speak
up I'm wearing it all got my technique
down and everything I don't be tickling
enough